[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce jour nouveau journal
d'information locale elle nous sommes le
mercredi 27 octobre voici les titres de
cette édition
octobre rose un mois pour sensibiliser
au cancer du sein des dépistages sont
organisées sur le territoire et pour
cette dernière semaine les
professionnels de santé viennent à vous
des unités mobiles ont été mises en
place pour aller à la rencontre des
yvelinoise le procès de nuremberg en
reconstitution alu fr à simone veil de
saint quentin en yvelines étudiant en
droit sciences politiques et santé se
sont rassemblés autour d'une pièce de
théâtre la mise en scène du procès des
médecins nazis s'est tenue hier à
montigny le bretonneux tout le temps
d'une représentation
et puis vinifie cas le club d'oenologie
vie si noah est arrivée 6e lors des
championnats du monde de dégustation de
vins à l'aveuglé en octobre nous sommes
allés rencontrer les membres de l'équipe
pendant leur préparation aux
championnats de france et on commence ce
journal avec les derniers chiffres de
pôle emploi publiés aujourd'hui et
d'après ces données le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi sans activité a
diminué de 1 58% sur les trois derniers
mois dans les yvelines 69 mille
personnes sont concernées une baisse
plus importante si on compare aux
chiffres de septembre 2020 en un an le
chômage de catégorie à c'est-à-dire la
catégorie de personnes sans activité a
baissé de 6 % dans le département une
évolution expliqué par la relance de
l'activité économique après plus d'un an
et demi de crise sanitaire la situation
dans le département temps à retrouver
son niveau d'avant crise plus de
soixante quatre mille personnes étaient
concernées
[Musique]
en france seulement 48% des femmes
répondent aux démarches de l'état en vue
d'effectuer lé dépistage du cancer du
sein un pourcentage qui est encore
beaucoup plus faible dans les quartiers
populaires à plaisir une opération a été
menée ce mercredi 27 octobre dans le
quartier du val hibou pour sensibiliser
et dépister gratuitement elle est femme
qui le souhaitaient reportage de bixente
mais rien senti steban souriant il vous
met à l'aise sans aucune crainte grâce
au mam au but s'installer dans le
quartier du vally boas plaisir isabelle
a pu faire un dépistage du cancer du
sein sans rendez vous préalable et
gratuitement même si c'est remboursé par
la sécurité sociale il faut quand même
avancer les frais et tout le monde ne
peut pas les avancées des marchés de
organiser le dépistage du cancer du sein
au plus près des habitantes avec un
dispositif hors les murs avec deux
unités aux mille la première le maho bus
où on fait des ateliers de prévention
une rencontre avec un médecin et dans la
foulée la patiente va dans le camion
d'octobre rose à faire ça mammographie
son échographie est reçu par un
radiologue et repartent le soir même
avec un compte rendu au centre de
l'organisation le bailleur social des
résidences yvelines essonne qui a
mobilisé les gardiens de ces résidences
plaisir oise pour faire venir les femmes
des logements sociaux on a pu
interviewer le radiologue et déjà au
terme de ses deux premiers rendez vous
aucun aucun des aucune des deux femmes
n'avaient déjà réaliser une mammographie
voyez toute la pertinence du projet au
départ l'initiative a été faite
justement pour les quartiers dits
populaires et quartier ou peut-être les
femmes ont plus de difficultés à faire
la démarche d'aller trouver un médecin
et de prendre des rendez-vous 24
habitante se sont inscrits et plus d'une
dizaine sont venus son rendez vous pour
participer aux ateliers de
sensibilisation
effectué le dépistage on regarde
l'examen si y'a rien voilà on fait le
compte rendu ne donne à la patience il
ya quelque chose et bien sûr foule l'a
suivi dans deux autres examens irm
ponction et ses terrains et puis il faut
que venir le médecin traitant sa
gynécologue pour la suite c'est la
première fois que ce dispositif est
déployé en ile de france pour rappel le
cancer du sein affecte environ 58 mille
femmes par an dans le pays
toujours dans le cadre d'octobre rose et
general electric healthcare est l'un des
leaders mondiaux en termes d'équipements
d'imagerie médicale basée à buc
l'entreprise organise également des
opérations de dépistage cécilia olson
vous êtes avec nous m'ont soir en soie
où vous êtes patiente avocate oui vous
êtes avec nous vous avez une unité
mobile qui propose des dépistages
gratuits sur rendez-vous à versailles ce
sera notamment du 2 au 5 novembre on va
reparler dans un instant mais juste
avant je voudrais voir avec vous et vous
faire réagir sur cette information que
nous avons entendu dans le reportage 58
mille femmes seraient touchées par le
cancer du sein en france chaque année et
pourtant une femme sur deux ne se fait
pas dépister s qui aurait eu aussi un
impact peut-être par rapport à la crise
sanitaire oui a certainement manqué il
ya vraiment un phénomène de craintes des
gens de manière naturelle les femmes s
ont peur d'aller faire leur maman pas
par crainte delà de la douleur et après
il ya eu les c qu'ovide on a eu peur d'y
aller par pour pas tomber malade du coup
vide et aussi les femmes ont tendance à
a priori donner la priorité à d'autres
choses à d'autres personnes de la
famille donc elles sont pas elles sont
pas voulu je suis recherché surcharger
les les urgences au dot pour aller faire
leur maman elle donne donc là vous
disposez d'un camion qui depuis le début
du mode dr en fait est déjà passé par
plusieurs villes dont versailles la
semaine prochaine au total il y aura
donc quinze villes qui ont bénéficié de
cette opération pourquoi c'est important
de partir à la rencontre finalement elle
des franciliennes plutôt que de les
accueillir dans les locaux parce que
comme on sait que les femmes ne prennent
pas le temps et on essaie vraiment de
reconstruire leur parcours de soins et
de laisser attraper là où elles sont
parce qu'elles ne prennent pas le temps
donc elle donne la priorité à d'autres
choses que leur maman donc on a décidé d
équiper ce camion là avec d'autres
partenaires donc ce ce camion d'octobre
rose et on va
essayez les endroits où on sait que les
femmes déjà elles sont peut-être pas
culturellement sensibles à ça et puis
comme je décèle à d'autres priorités
donc on va à l'encontre des femmes donc
il y aura des séances de dépistage
gratuite mais ce sera sur rendez-vous
comment on peut avoir accès justement à
ces rendez vous ces séances oui alors on
est en partenaire a aussi avec kate octo
libre donc il fallait chercher le camion
d'octobre rose sélectionné sa ville et
leur qui comme bien la femme donc c'est
vrai qu'on a eu beaucoup de succès mais
je suis sûr qu'à encore quelques
quelques datait de dorian disponibles
pour les femmes il y aura également des
ateliers de palpation notamment pour
apprendre aux bahamas examiner c'est
important absolument parce qu'il ya
toutes les femmes ne sont pas éligibles
pour la maman parce que évidemment en
dessous de 40 ans on s'expose pas au
rayon donc il ya quand même deux femmes
qui s'intéressent de près parce que il
ya quelqu'un dans la famille queveau
cancer de sein donc avec des mots
simples des gestes simples on montre
comment découvrir son corps et ressentir
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait normal
voilà et dans la durée il faut faire ça
et donc vous vous êtes pêcheurs ou kate
c'est à dire que vous êtes là pour faire
de la prévention en amont par rapport à
votre même propre histoire absolument
donc j'ai eu un cancer de sein en 2015
donc quand je suis revenu effectivement
ma mission elle était toute différente
travaillons pro general electric et et
qu'on ait sens de l'histoire des femmes
elles sont ceux dont elles ont tant
besoin d'entendre pour ne pas avoir peur
on sait que des flyers au des brochures
dans les salles d'attentes n'ont pas ou
peu d'impact donc des paroles entre
femmes des survivantes du cancer de sein
c'est vraiment ça complètement notre
impact sur leur santé et la perception
des femmes sur la mammo donc le nom fait
de la prévention justement par rapport à
ça c'est avec des mots simples
détourner leur attention de la douleur
et comprendre pourquoi le faire et en
quelques mots expliquer ce que c'est
vraiment un cancer de sein de quelques
quelques faits est tirée d'une histoire
d'une femme et elle se rend bien compte
que la douleur ou l'inconfort d'une
maman ça n'a rien à voir avec qu'est ce
qu'on aime quand on est exposé à un
cancer de sein à l'impact pour la
famille les enfants donc elles
comprennent bien que une petite mamos et
ce n'est rien à côté d'un cancer ii
s'annonce avec de bons simple en échange
il ya beaucoup de faire la parole c'est
vraiment libéré dans ce camion parce que
parce qu'on a entre femmes qu'importe
les cultures et dont bien on est juste
et femmes avec les mêmes les mêmes
questionnements par au corps le cancer
et comment comment juste savoir si ça va
bien on pas dans son corps donc c'était
des rencontres incroyables et donc la
semaine prochaine vous serez à
versailles jusqu'au 5 novembre cris est
ce que vous aller sillonner la ville où
est ce qu'on peut vous retrouvez un
endroit précis dans la ville alors
lèverait se trouve sow d'octo l'ipch
palabres et sans en tête mais je pense
que ce rose le site internet vous pouvez
trouver ça et surtout ce dock tôt les
bancs en prenant rendez vous voilà donc
ne pas hésiter à prendre rendez vous
pour participer à l'opération c'est ça
merci beaucoup et pire on merci beaucoup
qui on le rappelle donc il est fortement
recommandé d'effectuer une mammographie
tous les deux ont dès l'âge de 50 ans
même si on n'est pas les éligibles avant
mais pour prévenir le cancer du sein
merci beaucoup d'avoir été émoussée
cedeao le sun news est payante advocate
[Musique]
mardi 26 octobre aura lieu la première
représentation de la pièce projet
nuremberg à l'ufr simone veil santé un
projet pluridisciplinaire qui mêle les
étudiants de la faculté de droit de
sciences politiques mais aussi de la
faculté de santé c'est une expérience
d'éloquence de l'histoire et de
l'éthique un reportage de bixente mais
rien senti steban et céline charles
cela fait plusieurs mois que ces
étudiants volontaires travaillent sur le
projet une pièce de théâtre de 35 pages
qui retrace le premier procès de
nuremberg la démarche c'est une démarche
qui a commencé il ya plus de trois ans
avec l'idée de combiner théâtre droit et
santé il ya deux ans la thématique fut
celle des procédés médecin nazis
n'étaient pas tous résident ailleurs des
médecins dans deux procès de nuremberg
gonds entre 46 et 47 on a évidemment
tout ce qu'on retrouve dans un tribunal
à savoir l'accusation la défense les
juges et donc les accusés que nous
représentons derrière un procès qui
condamnait les médecins nazis et qui est
à la naissance de la bio éthique
médicale pour la première fois la
question du consentement dans les
expérimentations sont pas abordés
l'important c'est de soulever le débat
parce que la question des
expérimentations médicales est toujours
d'actualité et aussi de comprendre à
quel point une médecine pourtant
exemplaire qui était celle allemande a
pu super v retire ça mais au sens l'idée
que le patient doit donner son accord et
doit être volontaire et cette notion de
volontariat notamment qu'elle est au
centre de toutes les questions lorsqu'on
est enfermé dans un camp de
concentration est quelque chose qui est
vraiment inscrits dans un code et ce
code finalement va compléter le serment
d'hippocrate et s'appliquer à la
recherche biomédicale
les professeurs à l'initiative du projet
souhaité transformer la transmission du
savoir en plongeant les étudiants
directement dans l'histoire le but
moderniser l'apprentissage à travers du
travail de la représentation théâtrale
et ben c'est eux qu'on entend c'est eux
qui font sonner ses mots et donc pour
l'enseignant bassin selon passionnant de
voir pour se matérialiser finalement un
certain nombre de concepts d'idées à
travers la bouche des étudiants ça une
grande résonance nous dans nos
spécialités médicales c'est que l'on
sait à quel point il est important
actuellement d'avoir le consentement des
patients travailler avec des étudiants
c'est c'est super de pouvoir travailler
avec des jeunes qui ont un an vi qu'en
fait ils se sont vraiment porté
volontaire pour le faire et que ça anime
de restituer sa sur scène voilà il était
super enthousiates d'autres
représentations sont prévues par la
suite et seront suivies de débats sur la
bioéthique
les usagers de la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines n'auront plus besoin de
dévier leur route pour prendre le train
la circulation dans la gare située à
montigny le bretonneux et bien d'être
rétabli ce mardi 26 octobre une
déviation via la passerelle rouges
avaient été mises en place depuis le
mois d'avril en raison de travaux
d'accessibilité et des voix pour rappel
le chantier de modernisation de la gare
a débuté il ya un an il se poursuivra
jusqu'en 2023 à la phase 3 des travaux
devraient débuter début novembre et puis
le projet de quartier des savoirs à
guyancourt avance petit à petit la ville
et l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines ont signé une convention
d'intervention foncière avec
l'établissement public foncier d'île de
france et leurs établissements publics
d'aménagement paris saclay pour le
secteur du technocentre renault
l'échéance de cette convention est fier
au 31 décembre 2000 29 elles concernent
notamment des terrains sur le site
technocentre renault
[Musique]
5 équipes du club d'oenologie vinifie
cas de voisins-le-bretonneux ont
participé au championnat de france ce
samedi 23 octobre à menetou-salon dans
le département du cher une équipe a
remporté la première place se qualifiant
directement pour la grande finale qui
aura lieu au mois de juin elle les
autres attendent début décembre pour
disputer est la deuxième manche mais
alors comment font-ils pour reconnaître
un vins à l'aveuglé le reportage de
céline charles
sylvain toutes les 10 minutes c'est ce
que doivent dégustés à l'aveuglé cinq
équipes du club d'oenologie de
voisins-le-bretonneux pour le
championnat de france l'objectif est de
trouver les caractéristiques précises
des vins dans cette feuille nous devons
mettre le cépage majoritaire
l'appellation le producteur le nom la
cuvée au cas où vraiment on a on a des
bonnes sensations et qu'on trouvera la
d'écouté et le millésime qui correspond
aux vins que l'on a dégusté nous allons
déguster en général 80 blanc et 80 rouge
est sûre c'est sur ces vins là il va
falloir trouver le cépage principal
l'appellation le millésime
éventuellement le monde du propriétaire
a le nom de la cub réunit un soir par
semaine les membres de ce club créé en
2005 participe au championnat de france
de dégustation depuis plusieurs années
c'est un des plus gros clubs de france
avait 85 membres des grands dégustateurs
en france un peu la france a
d'une part une grosse activité viticole
mais également beaucoup d'amateurs
passionnés
et
voilà le fort du club ici c'est la
complicité et puis aura envie d'avancer
ensemble et puis transmettre beaucoup de
transmettre tous les vins qu'on va
déguster chacun une personnalité donc il
faut arriver à détecter tout ça un
entraînement est très importante
dans notre
rôle de compétiteurs servir tournée
sentir goûter tous les sens de ses
compétiteurs sont éveillés face aux
verts pour deviner mémoire et régularité
sont les mots d'ordre avant le verre on
va regarder le la couleur du vin là ça
va donner avec déjà une première
indication ensuite on va faire première
analyse objective en train de faire
tourner un petit peu le vin pour avoir
des arômes qui sont plus lourds qui vont
qui vont sortir plus facilement
et enfin ensuite on va le mettre en
bouche
[Musique]
des gens qui sont plus réceptifs que
d'autres bien sûr
il ya la lfh actif il ya la mémoire la
mémoire qui est très importante la
grande finale devrait se dérouler en
juin prochain espérons que cette année
soit un bon millésime pour eux
et l'arrivée de l'hiver est une période
plus propice aux troubles de l'humeur ce
phénomène est reconnue est appelée à
trouble affectif saisonnier mais à
défaut d'avoir du soleil les médecins se
tournent parfois vers la luminothérapie
un nouveau traitement doux c'est le cas
de la clinique a dit bin abd et l'église
en yvelines le reportage de bixente
mayence insisté ban regarder bonjour
désordre alors dites moi et j'ai mal
dormi
ça vous dirait une seule a pris
le soin par la lumière un traitement de
plus en plus utilisé par la clinique
d'yveline la patiente se plaint d'avoir
mal dormi elle se sent fatiguée elle a
besoin de récupérer un petit peu ce
matin
du coup nous avons nous allons choisir
le programme turbosieste qui se déroule
en cinq minutes un peu plus de cinq
minutes le choix se fait parmi une
vingtaine de programmes la
luminothérapie est utile pour la gestion
du stress la dépression ou encore
l'alcoolo dépendance qui est plus ou
moins de février j'ai déjà bien entamée
jeu j'avais du mal à me faire
j'étais très anxieuse
n'est pas si négative 1 les alcools
c'est bien mais vivre sens il faut la
prendre à lumino à la porte
pour moi elle m'a apporté de la détente
de lâcher prise en neuf mois de pratique
65 séances ont été effectuées à la
clinique d'yveline 85% se sont déclarés
satisfaits par cette méthode tous nous
savons que les médicaments ne peuvent
pas tout faire un patients dépressifs
qui est sous traitement antidépresseur
mais à peu près six mois pour aller bien
en discussion associés sous traitement
anti dépresseur à de la luminothérapie
au bout de trois mois
parfois même moins de trois mois le
patient s'améliorer en raison d'un
phénomène appelé trouble affectif
saisonnier la période hivernale est plus
propice aux troubles de l'humeur
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis demain
retrouver grégory canal et à la
présentation de votre journal local ce
sera en direct sur tv 78 à 18h très
bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]